here they got to the nba because of
their athleticism
anthony simmons is all around playing
simon those two guys
they're dunkers i'm going with cassius
he's been doing this since he's 15 16
years old
shout out to jerome's town you've done a
wonderful job raising your son all right
i was gonna go with caches but i gotta
go against
oh wow you don't have to just say what's
right i'm gonna go away you know we just
say what's right man we know what this
is
i'm gonna go with efforty because this
this guy's been doing this
he can fly he's on the radio right now
okay
cassius stanley on a two-way contract
indiana pacers fort wayne mad ants of
the g-league
has not had a dunk in an nba game yeah
this counts
two field
he's been waiting for this moment
because he made it on first
[Applause]
first dunk no warm-up no sweat all four
setting the stage left hand he's doing
what steph curry did in the three-point
contest
putting a little fear in everybody but
i've watched castle's play
i'm from l.a area he went to sierra
canyon i've watched him
he's been waiting for this moment his
whole
life you watch you cashless play i watch
my heart when i leave too
bad oh man the champ is here
four nines and an eight oh no this is
tough
come on dominic that's a ten man that's
a ten man no apparently it's not
that's a tent man
the force that he does and the strength
that he did it and how high he was
they give him all a ten he has nowhere
to go no he does
you gotta beat that dump that is a 10
dunk in any contest
all right obi topping at 6-9 the tallest
dunker
in the field of 20-21
and he's uh he's had 18 dunks this year
with the new york knicks
in his rookie season not more important
than this one ernie
and had the most in college basketball
d1 at dayton
last year this tarsal matters sack
yeah sack i think his size might
[Applause]
[Music]
that was a great dunk but i don't think
it was better than skashes and stuff
that was a great dunk but the height
the electricity that cass has had on the
first dunk
but this is this is yeah
that was that look was
[Music]
if zach levine didn't do that last week
in the layup live
if he didn't do that last week in the
lab live that's it
come on man i keep up with this i ain't
new to this i'm true today that's the
eight and two that's three eights and
two nines
and two dollars 48. they jerking my man
cashes
oh i'm not saying that that wasn't a
great dunk but that wasn't a 10 dump
if if cassius wasn't a 10. both derks
were very impressive yeah no question
you know dominique ain't on social media
though he ain't see the dunk last week
that zach
yeah none of them have social medias but
that's not an easy dunk though this one
it's not an easy dump but you think this
was easy
sucked but it was easy but it probably
was easier than that one
maybe maybe what hurt cassius is he made
it look
so easy for a 44.
these guys this guy anthony simon's got
some easy hops he can really get up
oh he's going with the he's going to
know
and a nerf ball i bet he dunks a nerf
ball
[Music]
top of the square that's that's like uh
almost 11.
i remember those things feet yeah i
remember
12 feet go get that he's 6-3 go get that
it was impressive but he made it look
too easy
that was impressive though but he made
it look too easy
i think it looks more impressive because
he's smaller and i like i
like the originality of that because we
haven't seen it
let me see he wouldn't got that freeze
it there oh give me
that he went and got it he wouldn't got
that
oh he got that
i got to put on what cash this was then
i got to put him in that same room he
got it
he weighed
[Music]
but he didn't go get it there's a
difference
numbers out here's a look from the att
5g slam cam so this dunk falls
in between the other two 44 46 and 48
and they each have one more dunk in this
first round
come on dominique you know better i
don't know i think
i don't even think spud has a uh a
social media account
you know what best one i saw in that
first round anthony simons
[Music]
he didn't go get it